Are you preparing for AWS interviews?
Learning random questions and then
forgetting the answers in interviews
very journal problem and don't do this
mistake. Cracking interviews needs smart
preparation. Remember focus more on
important questions not all. So in this
video I will show you the top 10 most
important AWS interview questions
especially if you are a beginner in AWS
and not just definitions I will explain
each question step by step like this
with simple diagrams so that even if you
are new to a AWS still you will
understand each and everything. After
watching this video, you can easily
explain the answers in your interviews
and you will be ready to face your next
AWS interview with confidence. So let's
start with the first question.
What are the main cloud service models?
Explain the difference between is pass
and SAS with AWS example. Now maybe you
have heard about this before but today
after listening to the answer you can
explain this to anyone. Okay let me give
you my own example. So when I was a
developer, I was 90% time focused on the
application code and the database.
But but but to manage one production
application from start to end, many
things are needed to manage an
application in your company. This full
computing stack is required. Here are
different layers. Okay. At the top this
developers are handling this application
and data. This is managed by developers.
Okay. Then there is the IT or the infra
team who in do the bottom task like the
runtime runtime like for example you
install Java runtime, net framework on
the server, NodeJS frameworks. So that
done by the IT team. Then your
application might need some middleware.
Middleware like MS Office uh some third
party software your application need MS
office SAP or something other some other
API. Okay. Below that OS like Windows
server your application is hosted or the
Linux server. So that IT team will
install. Then virtualization is required
to simulate the hardware. Okay. Then
physical servers definitely where your
application will be hosted. That
physical server must be secured, updated
and monitored, right? And IT team will
also install the antivirus to uh secure
your servers.
Next we have the storage. storage
because your application have some
images, they have some files, it have
some files, some database. So, some
storage on the uh server is required.
And finally, the networking part.
Networking on server is required to
connect all the servers databases
together. So this is the entire setup
from runtime to networking which is
handled by the IT or the infrastructure
team. So both developers and IT team
work together for your company. Okay.
Meaning this fully onremise setup is
handled and managed by your company own
only. Okay. And honestly it's a lot of
work. Now AWS or any other cloud
platform provides three major cloud
service models to lighten and to make
your work simpler your company work.
First model is AAS infrastructure as a
service. In infrastruct IAS
application data runtime middleware OS
will be managed by your company. Okay.
But virtualization, server, storage,
networking will be managed by AWS. So
your company work is less now, right? So
infra uh basically infra team has less
work to do, right? Second most popular
is platform as a service. This is the
most plat uh popular cloud uh model.
Okay. Here your company mostly focused
on application and data only. Okay. Rest
of the things runtime, middleware, OS,
networking, server, storage. So
everything is managed by AWS. Okay.
Third model is software as a service
SAS. And here everything is managed by U
AWS including the application and the
data. Okay. Your company just have to
subscribe and use this software. For
example, if you have heard about Amazon
workmail or sales force or office 365,
these are SAS platforms. Your company
just uses these services as a user. Your
company do not have to develop code or
configure anything in the AWS. No
technical work is required in SAS. Okay.
So that is the simple story of IAS pass
and sa uh SAS. And now listen carefully.
All these are just we discussed this
application data runtime. These are
layers not actual AWS services.
Each layer includes some specific
services. For example, there is a
service Amazon EC2. It is the part of
the servers.
Okay, servers server layer. So, Amazon
S3 or EBS are actual services and part
of the storage layer. Okay. So as a AWS
developer you will mostly working on the
implementing AWS services not the layers
layers needed for the understanding.
Okay. And in the upcoming question we
will focus on services not layers. But I
hope now layers are clear to you. And
also you know you know that mostly you
have to work if you are a AWS developer
you have to work on I or pass because on
premise is completely different. It is
physical servers. It's not cloud and SAS
AWS uh developer do not have to do
anything. It's just a service which your
company has to do directly. That's it.
Okay, great. So that is the whole idea
of these three cloud models. If it is
clear to you, write crystal clear in the
comments or chat box that will boost
your confidence and help you remember
this forever.
And yes, I have also added minimum
definition and description of all the
layers in this book. So that I already
explained it uh but yes I have given it
here in the book so that if you later
want to revise then you can revise
quickly from the book. Okay. Again don't
try to memorize it. It's not needed but
try to understand it. Okay.
What are the main categories of AWS
services? What are the top 25 services?
Now, let me show you first AWS
management console. Here it is. If you
log into AWS, then this is your AWS
cloud console where you can use the AWS
services. Here, if I will click this
view all services of AWS. Okay. See all
these are like this compute uh developer
tools machine containers storage and
many more these are the categories okay
and now each category have many services
this compute have EC2 light sale many
many services okay so in short there are
hundreds and hundreds of services
provided by AWS but but but it's not
possible for anyone to learn or use all
of these services right that's why now
let's come back to the slide and here I
will list top 25 AWS services that are
the most important and used 80% of the
time in your application you can build
80% of the application by using this
just 20% services
first category is compute service second
category is database. Inside this we
have the main services also I have
written here. Then we have storage. Then
we have networking and content delivery
category. Next messaging and integration
and the security services. And the last
one is the infra and devop services.
80 to 90% of the application only need
these services I have written here. So
for example, if you want to de if you
are a developer then you need to host
your application you can use this EC2 or
you can oh sorry or you can use the
elastic bean stack or lambda or ECS.
Okay if you want a database you can use
RDS. So I will explain all of these
services one by one in upcoming
questions so that you do not have any
confusion in these services at least and
most importantly I will explain when to
use which type of services when to use
EC2 when to use elastic bean stock for
hosting the application okay so based on
the situation it is required now that is
the important thing and these services
we are going to learn in the application
question uh applica we are going to
learn in the upcoming question and let's
move on
and yes if you have not yet accepted my
never give up challenge then do accept
it keep giving the interviews until you
get the success like these candidates
and the day you get success share your
success story with me write never give
up in comments to accept the challenge.
What is a resource in AWS? What is the
difference between a resource and a
service? Yeah, I know it sounds very
easy, but I don't want to take any
chance with any confusion. So, let's
quickly understand it. Let's go to my
AWS AWS management console. Here it is.
Here for example to host your
application you need EC2 instance. So
here is EC2 instance. Let's press it.
And
here it is. Now you will find the launch
instance option for EC2. Now listen
carefully. When I press launch instance
that means an instance of the EC2
service will be created in my AWS
account. Okay. that specific instance we
call a resource. So basically after
creating the resource I can use it for
any purpose in the cloud. For example, I
can host my application inside that EC2
instance and in the same way I can
create multiple resources in my AWS
account for different different services
also like uh RDS instance for database,
S3 instance for storage, lambda instance
for serverless function. So that's how
now let's go back to the slide.
For example, this is your AWS cloud and
there are many services available here
like this elastic pen. Okay. Now your
company a AWS developer can use any of
these services by creating instances of
them like this. Okay. And those created
instance in your company account are
called resources.
Okay. And you can name them as per your
convenience.
So if you are a developer just
understand it like uh AWS service is
like a class and AWS resource is like an
object or instance of that class. Great.
Now you are 100% sure what is a service,
what is a resource, what is the
difference. Here is the easy to remember
definition. AWS service is a tool or
feature offered by the AWS to perform
tasks like computing, storage, network
security.
AWS resource is an instance of that
service that you create, configure and
use in the cloud. For example, AWS
services like a class. AWS resources
like an object or instance of that
class. Okay. Now this simple diagram and
theory in this book will help you in the
quick revision for your interviews.
Now for a single application hosting you
have to create many many resources.
Now how to manage those resources that I
will cover in the upcoming questions.
What are AWS regions and availability
zones? how they are different from the
name itself you can understand region
means a some physical location. So for
example here is the world map and it
shows the reason these dot shows the
regions or the geographical locations
where AWS has multiple data centers. So
the all these dots blue dots are the
regions. Okay. Now as I mentioned
earlier your company do not need to
maintain physical servers in its offices
no onremise servicesers right instead
your company can simply subscribe to and
use cloud resources from AWS via
internet and your company have to choose
the AWS region which uh location is
closer to your company so that uh the
users of your company can get faster
access. Okay, here is the definition.
AWS region is a geographical area where
AWS has multiple data centers.
Now, what is availability zones? Within
a single AWS regions, there can be phys
multiple physical separate separate data
centers. These are called availability
zones. Remember AWS regions means AWS
services are fully available in a
location for example in Mumbai in North
Virginia, Singapore these are the
regions but the actual physical data
center location within each region are
the availability jones. So there are
multiple data center present inside one
region that is possible because if
tomorrow one data center is failed then
other data center will immediately
provide the backup. Right here is the
definition.
AWS availability zone is a physically
separate data center within a AWS
region. It ensures high availability by
protecting your application from failure
in a single data center. And that's
answer to this question.
Before moving forward, ask yourself just
one thing. What is the point of learning
AWS if you can't crack the AWS
interviewers? That's why I have created
a complete AWS interview preparation
boot camp for you with three powerful
tools. Number three, 200 plus AWS
interview questions from all the topics
step by step. Even if you are AWS
beginner, still you can learn everything
here. Also the real scenario- based
questions are covered. Then in this
smart excel you can mark questions
prepared or not prepared and therefore
you can track your interview preparation
progress like this. Second tool is this
PDF book for quick revision just before
your AWS interviews. And first tool is
10 AWS mock interviews to help you
practice just like the real interviews.
Many students have already cracked
interviews with my courses. You can be
the next. Remember just one missed
question can led to interview rejection.
Why take the chance then? Check out all
the links in the description. If
interested, great. If not, no worries.
Let's move to the next question.
What are AWS compute services? Name a
few of them. Now listen very carefully
to the answer. The answer is AWS service
that do computations are called compute
services.
Uh let me explain it. Okay, see compute
services are those services that handle
computations. Computations means
processing or executing your application
logic like uh you have processor in your
computer to process programs. Same way
for example
here are some AWS compute services
popular one. So Amazon EC2 elastic
compute cloud is an AWS comput service
because you can use it to it as a server
to host and process and execute your
applications. Okay. Then a uh AWS Lambda
is used for serverless computation. Then
AWS elastic beantock is also used for
deploying applications without managing
infrastructure
and then EC2 autoscaling is there for
you know used for scaling the EC2
instances automatically.
Now don't worry I will explain this in
detail in upcoming question but for now
just understand that these services are
used for computation processing and
that's why they are called AWS compute
services. Okay, here is the final
definition.
AWS comput services provide cloudbased
processing power, autoscaling and
execution environments for applications.
That's it. Now in the upcoming question
we will understand the first and very
important compute service and that is
EC2 in detail.
What are Amazon EC2 instances? When
would you use them in a project? To be
very short and simple, EC2 are just like
the servers where you host your
application. Here is a very simple
diagram. You have hosted one application
which is front end is hosted on this
physical server. Okay? and back end or
API server is hosted on this separate
physical server. Similarly, this is
onremise application. Similarly, in the
AWS clu cloud, we call these servers as
the EC2 instances like this. EC2 stands
for elastic compute cloud. In short,
mostly we use EC2 instance to host
application.
But like you can use the server for many
other purposes. Similarly, you can also
use EC2 instances also for many other
purposes like running the background
processes and others. It's just like a
CPU. Here is the simple and easy to
remember definition.
EC2 instance are cloudbased virtual
servers that allows to run application
without needing to buy or manage
physical hardware. That's it. Now you
may ask is EC2 is the best and the
simplest and the fastest for hosting
application.
The answer is no.
So which one is the best for hosting
application that I will share in the
upcoming question.
What is AWS elastic beantock? For what
purpose can you use it? If you are from
a development background then this is
one of the top AWS service you will use.
Now if you remember IAS which is stand
for infrastructure as a service then EC2
is the example of is meaning if you are
using uh EC2 then you are using is model
of cloud because to host application you
will also install the take care of many
things which are in I only okay so EC2
you have to manage many things you have
to install the operating system you You
have to for application hosting you have
to install the frameworks to host your
application many many things but there
is if you remember pass which is stands
for platform as a service then is this
model as a developer you only need to
provide the application code data
configuration and nothing else for this
you do not have to create the EC2
instance or configure load balancer or
manage the underlying these this
infrastructure. Okay, all of them
automatically handled by AWS. You just
need to create your web app API or
backend service front end and deploy it
using the elastic pin stack.
That's it. So whether you are building a
web app, a rest API, mobile back end,
you can use elastic bean stack of the
service of the AWS. Okay. And EBS lets
you deploy your application in the cloud
uh with few clicks only. It's the
simplest way to deploy or host your
application in AWS cloud. Here is the
simple and easy to remember definition.
AWS beanstack is a fully managed
platform as a service that enable
developers to deploy and scale also web
application and services without
managing the infrastructure.
Okay. So simple definition like this
will help you to revise easily uh from
the book before your interview so that
you don't forget the answers.
Now you may ask if Beantock is the right
choice, the best choice, simplest choice
for a hosting application then why we
have AC2?
Good question. So that I will explain in
the upcoming question. But yes, before
that I will explain some features of
bean stack uh so that you can easily
understand bean stack in a very complete
way and uh you will know that why beanto
is so popular. It is very popularly
used.
What is AWS storage? What are the types
of AWS storage? Now after listening to
this, you will feel more confident as a
developer. You know there are different
types of files that your application
handles. For example, there are readable
files like word file or PDF file. Then
there are images files like PNG or JPG
and also data files like CSV or uh text
files. Right? So to handle and to store
different types of data files in the
best way AWS provides different types of
storage services.
Okay. So the one the first is the very
popular one and that is Amazon S3 simple
storage service. S3 stands for simple
storage service. S3 is best used to
store unstructured data like images,
videos, backups, documents and more.
Okay, it is the most popular one because
nowadays everyone is creating videos,
watching videos, right?
And the videos you are watching right
now maybe it is also here hosted in some
AWS hosted website. If it is in AWS then
the this video is stored in S3 storage
only. Okay. Second type of storage is
Amazon EFS elastic file system. EFS
provides cloudbased shared file storage.
Okay. And the third type is Amazon EBS
which stands for elastic block storage
which provide block level storage. Okay.
Now I know I know I'm just giving
oneeline answer right now but don't
worry in the upcoming question I will
explain each of these AWS storage in
detail with the real example like when
to use which one. Okay, that I will
explain more because that in interviews
they will ask you when to use this
storage, when to use that storage like
this. Okay, but yes, now you know the
main types of storage. And here is a
simple and easy to remember definition.
AWS storage is a cloud-based storage
solution that allows you to store,
access, and manage data over the
internet safely and reliably.
I hope this diagram and definition in
this book will help you in doing the
quick revision before your interviews
from this book.
What is AWS Route 53? How does it manage
global traffic? Let's understand this
100%.
Imagine you are working as a lead
developer in a very big company like
Amazon or Microsoft and your application
is hosted globally in the AWS cloud.
Okay. For example, here you have uh one
set of EC2 instances like this in region
one, New York or any region. Okay. and
another set of EC22 instances are in
Mumbai. Okay. Similarly, you have users
who are accessing your applications from
USA and there are some users which are
accessing your applications from India.
Now you want that when the users are
sending requests from near USA users,
those should be redirected to New York
region like this because New York region
is close to USA users and they will get
the response faster. Right? For that you
can use Amazon Route 53 service like
this. Route 53 will receive all the
request and distribute the request based
on the closest region. So here when
users uh from India will or near India
will send the request they will be
redirected to the Mumbai region. So AWS
route 53 distributes user traffic based
on the location so that users uh request
goes to the nearest region and responses
faster that is uh the role of route 53.
But yes one more thing once the request
will reach this uh New York or Mumbai
region here you can set up the load
balancers it is possible inside those
regions and then you can equally
distribute the um uh request between the
multiple EC2 instances. Okay. So that is
the full picture and real use case of
root 53 in real projects. And here is
the simple uh definition.
Route 53 is a DNS-based traffic rooting
service that distribute user request
across AWS regions based on rules like
user locations or latency.
So what is the meaning of latency?
Location you understand latency. What is
the meaning of latency? latency. For
example, if region one, this New York
region suppose it is down or it is slow
for some time, then route 53 will
redirect the USA users also to the
Mumbai region to the region 2 because
region one New York is down that also
route 53 will manage and that is the
answer to this latency. Okay. So this
diagram and definition will help you in
revising the concept quickly from this
book. Now in the upcoming question I
will show you the what is subnet which
is which is like the kid or son of the
VPC only.
What is infrastructure as code? Explain
how it works in AWS. So explain cloud
formation. Very very good question and
by the end of this you will have a
complete understanding of the whole
process. So just like an application
developer writes code to build an
application then build an application.
Same way the DevOps teams writes code to
deploy that application into different
different environments. Uh let me
explain. For example, let's say you are
a developer. You create one application
inn net java or node. Then uh developer
pushes or code commit the code to the
source control like GitHub. Okay. If the
build is successful and everything
testing everything pass then the DevOps
team member will uh will manually pick
up the code DevOps team from the source
code and deploy the application using
some AWS code pipeline or AWS console.
So this is the part of CI/CD pipeline.
So DevOps team will manually deploy this
code into the dev environment then in
the staging environment and then in
finally when everything is passed in the
same code in the production environment
right and yes mostly in dev environment
only development team will deploy but
for staging QA or production DevOps team
deploy mostly. So far this looks very
good. But here is the problem. When the
DevOps team is deploying manually,
they also need to install some
dependencies on the server like they
have to install the RDS for database, S3
for storage, EC2 instances or other AWS
services that the application needs in
each environment. Right now imagine some
DevOps team member manually set up
everything including all dependencies
in fine very fine in the staging and Q
environment and application is working
fine but then the same team member or
some other DevOps team member just
forget one simple dependency in the
production depart environment because
it's a manual process. So what will
happen next? Application will crash
because of those misdependency
in the production environment right and
client will kill you. So that is the
problem and here we have the
infrastructure as code which will solve
this problem. Instead of manual step,
first we will remove this manual
deployment process. And now DevOps
engineers will write some code using
tools like AWS cloud formation or
terraform is a very you know it's a
outside
AWS tool but it's very effective very
popular also. So this code we will call
as IA infrastructure as code because all
the infrastructure will be written here
inside this code. So this code will also
be stored in the source control just
like the application code and it is
automatically provision all the same way
same way rest of the direct development
QA and production automatically with the
same configuration like all the
dependencies which are written in for
staging same dependency will be written
in the code for production also. Okay.
And because the IA code is version
controlled and uh it's reviewed just
like the normal code. So there is no
chance of missing any dependency, any
setup or any manual errors. You just
have to run the code to deploy the pro
uh the applications in the different
environments. Okay. And before uh
running the code definitely you will
test it multiple times, right? Just like
in the application. So that is the power
of infrastructure as code which will
remove the human manual errors from the
previous process.
That's it. If the concept is now very
much clear to you then write crystal
clear in the comments or chat so that
you remember this process forever.
Finally here is the simple and easy to
remember definition.
Infrastructure as code is a DevOps
practice that allows you to define,
provision and manage infrastructure
using code instead of manual process.
Okay. So in in the cloud in the cloud.
So that's it. This diagram and this
definition will help you in revision for
your interviews from this book very
easily.
Great job my friend for completing this.
Most will only talk but the way you have
finished this shows your seriousness and
dedication towards your AWS goal. Now if
this video helped you then there are
many more important questions left like
this. What is SNS? What is SQS? What is
DLQ? What is CloudFront? Cloudatch etc.
So all I have explained in my complete
AWS interview boot camp.
Many of my students have already used my
courses to crack their interviews. Now
if you don't want to miss a single
question for your next interview, then
check out the boot camp and book link in
the description below.